تخيلوا ان امريكا الدوله الاقوى اقتصاديا
في العالم هي كذلك صاحبه الدين الاكبر
بواحد وثلاثين فاصل اربعه تريليون دولار
ليس هذا فقط بل هناك شكوك تقول انها قد
تكون عاجزه في سداد هذا الدين بحلول الاول
من يونيو المقبل
هذا ومع استمرار عدم توصل الكونجرس لاتفاق
حول رفع سقف الدين وبالتالي هذا امر قد
يعود بالكوارث على الولايات المتحده
والاقتصاد العالميته لكن هناك سؤال كبير
لماذا لا يطبع الامريكان مزيدا من
الدولارات ليسدد ديونهم باختصار هذا
الخيار غير ممكن او مستحيل عمليا لانه
سيؤدي الى مشاكل اكبر بكثير فالولايات
المتحده لديها سقف في طباعه الدولار لا
تستطيع تجاوزه وهو 3% من ناتجها القومي
الاجمالي والا فسيفقد الدولار قوته
الشرائيه وترتفع اسعار السلع والخدمات ومن
ثم التضخم الاقتصادي ناهيك عن ان الولايات
المتحده لن تغرق وحدها فالصينيون مثلا
سيجدون انفسهم في ورطه فبالرغم من انه
اصبح في ايديهم المزيد من الدولارات الا
ان تلك الدولارات لن تساوي نفس القيمه
التي دفعوها عندما قاموا بشراء الديون
امريكيه
[موسيقى]